This is a wasp next.
In the wild, some of these nests are built
underground using clay or mud.
But you might be most familiar
with the paper nests --
the ones built out of saliva and pulp,
typically found attached
to buildings or trees.
And these guys can get big.
According to the Guinness
Book of World Records,
the largest wasp nest was 12 feet long
and 18 feet all around.
Now, we're all accustomed
to avoiding these nests,
because, obviously, wasps are scary,
but today we're going to go inside one,
because there are a lot
of fascinating factors
that make these nests work
for wasps and their babies.
So, let's cut into one.
Pretty easy to cut through this.
The hardest part was
definitely here at the top,
where you can tell the cells
are more dense and wider.
If I can give you a scale
for how big this is,
I mean, like, look at it next to my head.
This is like a brick
cellphone from the '90s.
The key to this type of nest
is the pedicel, or the root.
It's the foundation that the
entire nest is built off of.
These are the cells.
Wasps are like butterflies.
They're what's called
holometabolous insects,
meaning they go through a metamorphosis
before they become adults,
and these cells are basically their cribs.
Petrovicheva: The cells are open when they
first are produced.
The queen will lay their egg in there,
and then it'll get sealed off.
They're shaped similar
to a hollow cylinder,
or like a regular lead school pencil,
and there's a reason why.
Petrovicheva: The walls of the hexagon
hold the other cells.
Also, they're a compact space,
so you can get a lot of these cells
in very, very small space
while still having a
very strong structure.
Mills: They're also perfectly sized
to fit both the larva and its roommates.
Petrovicheva: Oftentimes there's some food
laid in with the egg, so when it hatches
it has the food in there already.
The drones move from cell to cell
in a circular motion,
making sure that each larva has food.
Some wasp species tear up
insects for the babies,
but other wasps take things further.
Mason wasps drop off whole caterpillars
for their children to eat alive,
while tarantula hawk wasps lay their eggs
on tarantulas they sting and paralyze
as a birthday feast.
Other species lay their
eggs inside their prey,
and once the larvae hatch,
they have a meal waiting for them
to chew their way out of.
Petrovicheva: Once the larva
is ready to metamorphose,
it'll become a pupa inside the cell still,
and then it'll hatch as an adult.
Mills: Since the cells are both the crib
and the cocoon for these wasp babies,
the nest must maintain
a stable temperature
with high humidity.
This means as much insulation as possible.
For these types of nests,
the domes are almost always
made of salivary secretions,
plant material, or paper or cardboard.
Petrovicheva: So, they
take wood, they chew it up,
and they mix it with
saliva to make a glue,
and then they lay it in thin layers.
The denser the layers,
the stronger and more
sturdy the structure.
After building the core structure,
the queen wraps the entire
nest in an envelope --
these thin sheets of macerated pulp.
This layer basically protects the comb,
or each layer of cells,
limiting the entrance
to one tiny little hole.
Scientists think this helps
to maintain the internal temperature
and humidity of the structure.
And more cones can be added
on with more pedicels,
sort of like expanding a mansion
with tiny little staircases
that the wasps can use
to get from one area to another.
So, now I know the question
on some of your minds is,
"Is there honey in a wasp nest?"
And the answer is no.
While both bees and
wasps pollinate flowers,
bees actually farm nectar
to turn it into honey,
the food source for their larvae.
Most wasps, on the other
hand, are meat eaters
and prefer a diet of
freshly chewed insects,
meaning you won't find
honey in their nests,
but you might find a lot of dead bugs.
So, the next time you
see one of these nests
and you're tempted to knock it down,
maybe back off.
Those wasps put a lot of effort
into building this crib for their babies.
We don't want to tick them off.